welcome everybody through that YouTube
hangout super excited to be here with
you again today second one of the day uh
this is an interesting topic for me
today I was asked to do an interview
talking about the future of tech the
future of startups by a company called
thunderbolt and I said hey why don't we
turn this into a YouTube hang out so
that my audience can benefit from the
interview as well and learn about this
cool company and what they're all up to
so I'm pleased to be joined by tolga and
lower life from Thunder both guys
welcome aboard hello how are you good
for my audience may not be super
familiar with what you're up to why
don't you just give a quick intro into
who you are which all about and then
let's dive into the questions sure
Thunderbolt we study the 2014 and we are
we are a technology company and
incubator that helps startups to get off
to get off the ground we actually built
their first MEP technology projects and
we helped them to raise funds and as
soon as they raise funds they can
actually actually establish sustainable
business and so far we work with 11
different startups nine of these
startups that we built their
technologies and two of them got funded
total 6.4 million dollars are our
applications our startups in total they
have raised 6.9 million dollars in two
years in the last two years since we
established Thunderbolt on my eye I am
coming from technology background I also
some gaming background i was at ye and i
worked with digital agencies interact
companies in the past before i started
selling my company and like our
Thunderbolts mission is to actually to
build in the first stock market platform
for for these digital startups digital
applications application-based startups
pretty much like that's what we are
working on right now and hopefully very
committing new projects we're going to
new fashion application like this
application coming up on
it's it's it's an interesting model what
we are doing and some sometimes people
and I'm going to exactly understand but
we are pretty much like this design and
technology arms of these startups so
that's that's how we can actually put
them to put it in the briefly in the
grid way so there's an entrepreneur who
has an idea for a tech project but
they're not the tech guy or girl the
Messiah the end there for example one of
our projects our partner and client they
wanted to build a fence for spinning
platform and they had absolutely no idea
about technology and up to use some
things as such real such project and we
became a partner and we build a platform
for them they know how to play fantasy
sports they know how to they know so
much about the platforms and they have
so much experience in it but they have
no technology knows so for that kind of
clients like people for example another
example no I think we lost them not sure
it happened in master connection we'll
see if they join in it's an interesting
it's interesting model because a lot of
times entrepreneurs don't have they have
the idea but if you don't have the tech
in house is typically super super hard
to get it off the ground to get it
funded I know a lot of entrepreneurs
write it to me and say I have this idea
of this idea for killer app or program
how do I find the right team we had our
raise capital I mean usually an investor
will not put money into any kind of
entrepreneur in the tech world that
doesn't have a tech background so I
haven't heard of this models potentially
see that in incubated with join to
provide that back end hey guys you're
back yes sorry for a second i had a
cruel mishu you're doing this through
google engga i had a creamy she say love
it no worries well that's good it's
interesting i just did a little bit of
talking while you guys are way that a
lot
I'm you know VCS and investors won't put
money into a tech company where there is
nobody who does tech a lot of times an
entrepreneur has a vision but if there's
nobody who can actually do the tech in
the business it's hard to get funded so
it's interesting that you would be that
tech resource for entrepreneurs and then
help them build scaling up so that's the
main issue in actually in the technology
industry i believe right now reason why
they're there there is actually so much
more potential in what you know as a
society we can build but the the
investor networks or the cdc company
seed level we see companies they have a
very limited dealflow they only invest
into people that they personally know or
or they have to build some relationships
with creative and it's like a 70 75
percent off of the deals are in that
investment world is happening in in that
cycle and if you are living in I don't
know like mid america or and yeah where
you even like is an immigrant like me
you may not have so many chances of
raising funds if you don't know the
right people and then from that you know
perspective when you look at it so what
can we do to make this actually to solve
this issue and we came up with you know
expanding our company into the currently
or we are already building applications
for these startups which is great I mean
we are a service company um but now we
want to you know let's change our model
and become like a with the new
regulations I actually forgot to mention
this digit there was a new regulation
change and equity crowdfunding industry
the biggest change actually happened in
the securities industry since nineteen
thirty three this is regular regulating
the crowdfunding rules and it actually
allows startups to go to public
investors in concert
jeanette idea stage and our goal is
actually to like i said now like you're
building with the acrylic technologies
or startups now with the new the with
the support of visa new regulations we
can actually view the stock market
platform and start selling the the
stocks of the great ideas to people test
the market and if the idea is great if
it's the crowdfunding campaign is
successful because everybody is
investing it's not donation-based like
crowdfunding regular crop onions is it's
like start start space so people are
going to be able to you know get get an
idea about the product and they are
going to be able to use it or they if
they like it they're going to buy the
stocks of the application i hate this is
actually great things can really change
the way that they're certain things were
working right now so if people believe
in it they will invest their money and
buy cassatt it's from public investors
so copy the top limit is million dollar
per project as soon as we raise these
funds we're going to be able to you know
fund these startups so much easier
because right now as you mentioned like
ninety-five percent of the startups when
they have great ideas they don't have
enough money to build the projects cool
well super interesting let's let's get
into the interview and see what happens
what do you guys have questions um
herself just um in your own words for
the sake of writing an article um can
you explain i I looked into your website
in your whole believe campaign and I
found it very um very simple but yet
very powerful um and I was wondering if
you could explain how you came to see
the power of believing in yourself to
reach success sure I believe came from
my parents I you know I had two sisters
who did really well in school and I was
always like the bean see students while
they were getting a's all the time
and every time come report card season
I'd have to sit down with my parents and
instead of them kind of yelling at me or
telling me I should do better they would
always tell me that I was a kiss truly
Carmichael my mom's last name is cuz
truly I was a ghost really chromatic I
could do anything I wanted and you know
eventually I got better and I soon
exceeded their expectations and kind of
burst through higher barriers and that
was a core belief for me is that just
the confidence be able to say like I can
do this I think entre first have to have
that like you look at on tours come to
you and pitching ideas if they don't
fully believe in what they're doing and
how absolutely certainly that's going to
work at nobody's going to fund them
nobody's going to partner with them
there was gonna like you guys wouldn't
take an equity position in a company
where the entrepreneur didn't fully
believe in themselves and in the idea
that they're getting into right like
you're producing technology for
entrepreneurs you know you you're
partnering up with these guys it's a lot
of risk for you to take on the only way
you do it all right the only what you do
is if they actually have a solid case
you know the markets they're all that
but just because a market is hot doesn't
mean you're just going to go into that
with a okay entrepreneur like that
person has to fully commit and believe
in what they're doing pretty cool and
they're doing yeah it's like the the
entry to get in it in don't love what
you're doing I was thinking we'd be
honest with you I probably lies you to
follow behind you thank you great answer
um so cycling from that um so a
thunderbolt we special we have as we
explained they specialize in helping
startups that want to disrupt their
industry as you mentioned it a market
being hot is not one thing but being
able to break the market is a better you
have a better shot and a 2013 study by
compuware shows that sixteen percent of
users will give apps a third a third
chance to impress them seeing
entrepreneurs and startups continue to
lead
ords the app market and app development
this is for both of you how do you think
how do you keep them motivated and
prepared to stand out in the crowd what
was the 16th for sixteen percent and
we'll give entrepreneurs or give our
third chance their kids yeah they'll
only use a nap twice if it doesn't if it
doesn't impress them by then right right
you know I don't know how much different
that is from regular business like would
you give a company three chances if they
haven't impressed you like if you go
into a local deli shop and you're going
for lunch and the first time you sucked
and the second time suck are you going
back at third time probably not i don't
know that that that number relates only
to the app digital world I think it's
everywhere and it's on you then to
create an amazing first experience like
when I come into your shop when i load
your app when i go to your website i
need to have an amazing experience of a
little find value and what i'm using
then why would i go back so i clear it i
don't think it's limited just to the app
world I think it's just business mm-hmm
closed beta testing is very important
some people they just want to go to
market right away and just blow it up
and show it all of their friends and but
that's not how it really works it's
actually they need to keep it in the
closed network for at least couple
months until they also understand what
they're doing like exactly because most
of the time there are applications that
people they predict things that this did
it be designed it this way or we build
it this way we predict that this is how
it's going to work up but in when it
comes to execution and in real life
they're always other other unexpected
issues that they come add that comes up
and when that's the reason why there's
so many startups there they get shocked
at all you know what's going to happen
what's how are we going to fix this it's
they don't understand the fact that the
development of applications and as what
you said it's not only like unique
should be beautiful when the user is
visiting the application it's also needs
to be always up-to-date and always count
development is a is a constant process
it's some people think that they're
going to give their applications and for
one year it's going to be great like
that it's not like that it's good it's
constant I mean I'd be able to date
about providing value if you provide
value you win design something beautiful
that could be value to uh you could have
something that looks terrible but is
highly functional and that's value too
if I'm using your app or going to your
store visiting your website I need to
get value back if I'm not going to get
value back I'm surprised that that many
people give a company a third chance
like even just getting the second chance
is going to be hard enough so you know
what encouraged the entrepreneur's
watching you got to make sure you're
giving value in every experience that
people have with your business yeah
people are more generous than you
thought yeah you know people thought you
their time you know would you go to a
coffee shop a third time if your first
and second experience sucked when
there's a million other coffee shops you
can go visit you know you look in the
world of apps how many new apps are
added to the app store every day I'm
sure you guys can tell me more than I
know myself tons of apps whatever app
you wanted you want to start a new
fitness app how many fitness apps are
there out there like would somebody give
you three chances added probably not so
you got to just make sure you're
providing value on that note in 2015 we
had the you know in this app tech bubble
that was expected to first what was
going through your heads during that
time and you know as someone encouraging
people to
bignum both the extra mile do you think
that we escaped it by the skin of our
nose or did we we just become better at
getting that investment money and
getting the apps out there demarcate um
sure I mean I don't think the bubble was
as big as other bubbles you see in the
past I also think people understand how
important mobile is going to be and
already is it's not it's not just the
future it's the now like compare how
much time people spend on their phones
versus desktop versus TV people are
already you know you look at YouTube
they've already come out and said
they're a mobile-first company like
there's already the mainstream movement
it's already happening it's no longer
the thing that's gonna be here in 10
years it's right now so because people
can see the tangible returns they're
still willing to put money in that's not
I don't think it's just about like
convincing investors that it's a good
idea i think that the market clearly
shows that this is where the action is
now whether this company or this company
this company is going to be the winner
you know who knows but this is going to
work one of these guys will be the
winner you know it's no longer maybe
this crazy thing is going to happen like
it will happen it is already happening
they just don't know which of the
company's it's going to be that will
take off I mean I I personally believe
that there wasn't actually a bubble
sometimes companies they especially
investors they missed so much money into
certain projects certain companies like
LinkedIn or XYZ like they just so
LinkedIn for 26 billion dollar because
the depth that was their best bet and
that company wasn't going to get higher
than that it was going to only go that
Dom because linkedin was a company of
2010 I mean still it's functioning but
what's going to happen in 10 years
nobody knows and forth from their
perspective they sold it and 2015
numbers for LinkedIn wasn't promising
and that was actually a huge variation
drop down
and now they get acquired for 26 billion
dollar which was not even expected so it
actually truths the fact that there
wasn't a bubble they just made out that
kind of speculation at the end of 2015
because the investors couldn't harvest
their money back but its technology to
see it's not always like that so it's
it's they make up that kind of like
terms just because the money is not
getting into their pocket but it doesn't
mean that there was a tick bubble as I
actually haven't mentioned we are living
in that age right now that there the
market is there it's an it's the biggest
growing market and constantly growing
market in the world app market
technology market and it's not gonna go
anywhere doll head back or any anywhere
lower than obvious right now in the
prison time so they join my person whip
there was definitely a huge job down in
the seed stage investments right now
because the amount of bully faith in the
projects are dropped but I think it's
also about some kind of I think it's a
phase it's going to change in the future
because everyone knows that technology
investment is high risk you know
whatever Liz is always right and back to
what we are talking about earlier Oh as
we're working on our equity crowdfunding
platform um do you think that everybody
crowd funding can be a way to deflate
send bubble whether it exists or not and
as less startups will have to rely on
going with IPOs yeah i think what equity
crowdfunding do is does is it it
democratizes the process of raising
capital just like the internet has
democratized everything right like it
started with ebay if you wanted to have
a store you don't have to actually have
a store now you can just go to ebay and
you set up your store now you look
at your B&B if you want to have a hotel
you've got a hotel in your house right
now right you don't need to go and buy a
hotel you have it there being be you
could be a taxi driver if you want
without going through all the training
and all the process and procedures but
just being an uber driver so the
Internet has democratized everything
youtube you know you want to be a
successful star you don't have to go to
TV and have to have the right contacts
and have to know the people the process
to get in you could just go on and start
your show I and talent becomes the
defining factor right so it's the same
thing with raising capital you know it's
going to go more and more that way we're
now we maybe you need to have the right
connections you need to know their ABCs
you may need to be in a certain
geographic market you know but as if we
get further further in it's going to be
less and less important like if you have
there's going to be the good ideas that
win the good execution that wins and
open it up to lots of other people by
crowdfunding it by making a market for
it just makes it easier and easier to
get the money that you have that you
need if you have a good idea just like
it's done for every other industry with
the internet so yeah I think if you have
the talent it's never been more exciting
to be an entrepreneur because the access
to the resources that might have been
harder to get out before are now
becoming more and more easy I completely
agree actually it's perfect I mean I I I
also for seed equity crowdfunding this
is it actually it's a good good example
I never thought about that but like how
licensing and music industry or the
acting industry changed by YouTube so
much and this is how equity crowdfunding
is going to change that intrapreneurship
will rule because there's a huge need
for this already there's so many people
who are trying to do things they don't
want to broken nine-to-five jobs they
just want to do their own busyness
because now with the internet and
mobility of everybody the it's possible
and why not like you know it
there are going to be huge changes and
actually finance industry to in relation
to to these changes because the JOBS Act
it's not only crowdfunding it's also
like allowing all these lenders and
private lenders that market the finance
industry in lending industry to be also
democrat eyes as well you know there's
going to be doing any huge big changes
in the banking industry as well it's a
lot of things are actually slowly
changing really we may not able to track
always everything because as it's been
having a panic slowly but if you take a
look at it last 2025 years so many
industries like transportation to
banking finance they expect media
everything is being disrupted by one by
one by the East Indies your forms yeah
and as capital becomes easier to acquire
and raise there's going to be just an
insane growth and number people trying
to raise capital and and that's what the
talent stands out like how many people
are starting YouTube channels now and in
sucking they see somebody doing well on
youtubes I go I could do that and then
they get on and they don't do a good job
they don't put in the work they don't
have the talent so now that people are
going to read stories about how easy it
is to get funding and how you don't need
to go to a venture capitalist anymore
and here's this great platform more more
entrepreneurs will jump on but the thing
that will make you stand out is the
talent is the drive is the belief is a
good idea as the execution is the team
on all the stuff that mattered that
matters now when going to see a B C or
an angel is still going to matter it
just makes it easier to get to the right
people easier to get to the funding so
you can focus on execution and building
a business instead of like when you're
out fundraising that's a full-time job
and exists the way from you being able
to actually execute on your business so
if you take away the headache of raising
money it's a lot easier you can dig down
focus more on execution but you're gonna
have a lot more competitors now like
everybody's going to want to sort of
business because it's so
easy to get access to the money so the
talent in the execution is going to be
the key thing that separates you to help
you build the business up but you're
right about the fundraising is a
full-time job it is and that's what I've
been doing for the last one year one
year it's been like very very hard
especially as we are not based on Sam SF
the area and Ally and it's a computer
landscape when it comes to the
investments and a lot of people I mean
when they come to our offices when they
want to talk to us we sometimes you get
treated like you know what do you what
do you guys do here like because if
people don't expect the LA native people
should be proficient in technology i
guess i don't know why they always have
like superficial expectations from
people but there is actually what I
realize there's a huge talent crazy
amount of talent that is actually hungry
and do a lot of a lot of tech projects I
mean the entertainment is here um the
Hollywood actors models yes and they're
always going to exist it's just la is
the best of these people but there's
also you know the growing as everything
is changing there's also a huge drawing
community of technology people like and
there's a huge potential in that and
hopefully in the next five to ten years
I am also seeing LA as becoming a new
technology up after a set that's what
I'm thinking well by the way I forgot to
ask do you have an where are you located
in LA I'm in Toronto I mean I'm in
Toronto Canada wow that's crazy most of
my audience is American but I'm
physically based here in Toronto nice
it's funny before I moved to Southern
California originally Turkish I was
going to come to Toronto to be in a
Seneca College there you go ignor I like
it
being Canadian story there um the last
bit are we save time for was audience
Q&A do you have questions on your end
everything sure yeah you know we've got
a couple minutes so guys watching if you
have a question you can leave it in the
comments and we'll answer it um what are
you looking for when you're bringing on
a new entrepreneur to invest in so what
do you look it would win the deal new
potential deals coming to you I entren
with a great idea what are the things
that you look for mean we talk about
believe but one of the one of those
other things that you look for mainly
for the idea the concept has to be a
business idea as just we make money has
to have a sustainable business idea but
mainly I'm not going to lie as we are
profit within us too we are looking for
hey I mean yes we can do you can help
you as much as possible but do you have
funding because these technology project
if these applications are not like cheap
you know not everybody can not
everybody's family and friends can fool
hundred grand or turn their grand to
build an application so that's what we
ask mainly do you have funding it has to
be a great business idea and the people
needs to be I mean um from going back to
my la conversation there's so many
people also in this town they think that
they're entrepreneurs but they they have
terrible lifestyles and they I don't
know how that's gonna work and there's
so many people like that to you like not
doesn't fit the founder and CEO
personality mean because it's living in
the in depth lifestyle is is be me
founder and CEO is a another another
dimension you need to completely
dedicate your entire existence to that
company and like some people don't have
that kind of kind of profession as
however you mentioned I mean we need to
believe in those people
but yeah overall these are the three
main things if they have in a funding
enough funding or if they have a good
personality you're correct it takes to
be a CEO and great sustainable business
idea from my end when i'm doing an angel
deal i'll look at the person to see the
song that i want to work with for the
next you know five years of my life you
know do they take feedback are they open
to it you know do we get along we don't
have to be best friends but we have to
be able to to get along I don't want to
be next to somebody who i'm i'm hating
and doesn't take feedback and tea i also
look for in an industry where i feel
like i can add value I feel like an ad
general business value to any industry
but I'd love you to come to a company
where I can you know there's some kind
of relation to entrepreneurship somehow
and I can use my connections to help
that company grow it's not in some field
that's totally foreign to what i know
and i think a good angel investor will
do that you know if you're an
entrepreneur looking for money don't
just go to any angel investor because
they can write a check for you you know
that's that's that's dead money you want
somebody who can actually do some work
for you to introduce you to people give
you some advice make some connections
for you and not just kind of take money
so i look for that when i'm looking at
angel investment deals may be time for
one more question and then we're bumping
up against the clock Solman is asking
how can you be strong when the people
around you are hating on your idea um
that's a very good question okay because
I mean that's just like I think you have
to be very very pumped to you it's a
question that I asked myself everything
it's a good question guys I mean you
have to stick up it I mean you can
always come to your mind that you can
just quit right you know now it's not
working but what's going to happen if
you do that so I mean unless you have
an idea I guess you got to stick with
the one that you have I think that's
part of being an entrepreneur like you
you're doing something crazy you are a
little bit crazy you're going to have
people who say that you're crazy in that
this idea will never work I've never met
an entrepreneur who everybody around
them says that's the greatest idea ever
people will hate on your idea i think
what helps get you through is one
modeling success so look up to people
who who've had success look at the
famous entrepreneurs who you like the
most and look back in the early career
and you see the day struggle then it
wasn't easy for them and last people
hate on their idea i think it's creating
an environment for greatness it's hard
to do great things when you're not
surrounded by greatness so look at your
habits look at your teens look at the
books you read and the youtube channels
you watching the movies you you watch
and like what do you consume who the
people in your life are they is
everything around you just keeping you
where you are or you surrounded by
things that help you become a better
version of yourself so like up you can
start reading new books you can start
watching their YouTube channels you can
create better morning routines that make
you believe in yourself every day a lot
of people might stumble across some
video at three o'clock in the afternoon
and they get motivated for rest of the
day and believe in themselves and then
they wake up the next day and it's gone
like poof where where did that
motivation go so instead of having it be
by accident you design that into your
life like you start your day every day
was something that motivates you that
inspires you that makes you believe in
yourself more and you try to design your
life so that it's not everyday you're
always going to be insanely motivated
and you know this is going to be
definitely down days but you want to try
to mitigate that as much as possible by
creating of routine and habits and
surround yourself with people who build
you up and people are hating on your
idea all the time like maybe those
people shouldn't be in your life anymore
you know maybe you got to spend less
time with them and sometimes I can be
high like maybe that's your parents
maybe that's your wife or your husband
you know but at least limit the exposure
like if your mom really hates your idea
maybe you don't go see here every day
you know you limit that a little bit
because that could drive you nuts you
know you need the people and you like to
be ones who support you and often
requires you to like have your friends
gone out and done what you want to do
have they accomplish anything close to
what you're dreaming of doing with no
then you know maybe you need to start
having some new friends who have done
bigger things and who do see bigger
things from you as well alright as my
rent kind of it and also just add this
was very short thing healthy lifestyle
very important healthy lifestyle cool ah
so thinking I spend at a time when when
is this any of your gonna go up on your
blog um hopefully next week sometime
next week cope so we'll link it up in
the description below so you guys can go
check them out if you're just in the
company what they're all about the link
is there to thank you guys so much for
the time for joining us Thank You
audience for watching we need to believe
and I will see you soon thank you